Michael asks how do you define hustle
Michael this is funny because Sheila's
face cuz I could see him grinning this
was the first query 35 in 5 this is the
first question 150 questions that I can
like see from the corner of my eye
literally said I need to find hustle is
he good see this up this is because you
know I mean this is a challenging
question so first of all it's different
for everybody right but what I would say
hustle is to me is that when you have
passion around something that you were
squeezing every last bit of the juice
out of the orange right to me Hustle is
maximizing the energy you're putting
into somebody I'm blown away by people
saying that they're hustling and they
want to achieve these great things and
then their actions don't match it's like
saying you really want to lose weight
while eating a Big Mac right so to me
hustle would be putting all your effort
into achieving the goal at hand and for
me that means making every minute count
hiring a full-time assistant who's ever
I mean Friday night didn't happen
because I was hustling like every minute
like if I miss my 15 minutes to tape the
show I've missed my 15 minutes because
there's so much hustle my day there's no
you know there's no like hey I there's
no hanging out there's no like time
we're like if I get to do like one joke
with you guys as I'm walking in between
meetings we like to find out to be like
a rare acquaintance situation like like
a current stomach Lance Hustle is
putting it all in a line Hustle is
waking up one day the day before you die
and realizing you gave it your all into
the parenting of your children the
building of your businesses the four
lamp three that you wanted to do
whatever you define it's just you know
all-in emotionally and execution Airy in
theory and strategy and an execution oh
crap wait subscribe I need subscriptions
because I can't push this many right
hooks in social so subscribe